[Music]
you
hey everybody hopefully you've had a
chance to see Wonder Woman but this is
the new DC movie intro that you'll see
playing in front of it probably in front
of Justice League in November and then
in front of the Aquaman movie next year
now like Marvel changes their intro
every couple big phases like they had
one before Thor the dark world that just
changed in front of the Doctor Strange
movie so I'm expecting that DC will
change theirs every couple years is they
roll out a bunch of new films I tried to
pick out as many of these characters as
I could spot it's a little bit easier
for the ones that are in the foreground
but there are some that are just a
little too blurry in the background so
as I go through the video you guys can
let me know which ones you spotted
especially the really obscure ones but
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video but the thing about this
isn't so much the Holy Trinity Batman
Superman Wonder Woman Aquaman the movies
they have in production right now it's
all the side characters that you spot in
the background they're Easter eggs for
films that haven't even been planned yet
you have almost all of the Green Lantern
Corps
there's mojo in the background there you
have the Hawks you even have Atrocitus
sitting back here with Sinestro so it's
like all these big things that are going
to be happening that they haven't even
really announced yet now if they're
doing the Green Lantern Corps movie of
course you expect there to be a bunch of
deep cuts for Green Lantern movies but
the fact that they're including all
these characters so prominently it
almost plays like a full Justice League
cartoon where it shows you all the
really big characters and then zooms out
and says oh look at all this other stuff
that's coming - we're doing all of it
we're totally calling our shot so this
is like a slightly better zoomed in
version it doesn't have everybody from
the sides but like you can see Shazam
black Adam I love that you know how they
working with the rock so much so they're
putting him right up front here like
they're trying to say that all these
characters towards the center or getting
movies in the next couple of years all
these other characters off towards the
sides will probably show up eventually
so everybody's asking where's Green
Lantern in Justice League unite the
seven but there's only six members right
now and that includes the Risen Superman
who will eventually come back during
Justice League so everybody's like
where's Hal Jordan there's all
of rumors about the Green Lantern stuff
that's going on in the Justice League
movie it will definitely address Green
Lantern but I think the idea is is they
have so much stuff going on with the
characters that they're marketing right
now the five characters that they're
marketing now and it eventually start
marketing Superman they've even put him
on like a lot of the popcorn boxes in
the drinks that they're going to be
selling in front of the Justice League
movie so the movies mostly going to be
focusing on these characters but they're
not going to leave the Green Lantern
Corps hanging dry and there's nothing
like a character over here on all fours
that looks like big sin it would be
crazy if she showed up in a DC movie
somewhere but you also have all the
Justice League dark characters in here
too so you see swampthing way over here
on the end so it's almost like they told
geoff johns to include all of his
favorite characters just put everybody
that you want in there just full-on
fanboy for all the people that you'd
like to see in DC movies on the big
screen eventually what's going on here
though is that you pretty much have all
your marquee characters and then their
supporting characters not too far off in
the distance from them
so you see Nightwing Batgirl who are
definitely getting movies but you also
see Catwoman - so it's like wait a
minute does that mean we're going to see
Catwoman in the Batman movie that would
be amazing that'd be so awesome
there's this weird chemistry thing going
on with Batman and Wonder Woman right
now and all the footage that they share
together but I really want to see
Catwoman come back to this new DC EU the
Selina Kyle Catwoman but you see mirror
over here you see ocean master
there's Blue Beetle there's even Solomon
Grundy who knows when he's going to show
up but you also have Jessica Cruz so
there's also a lot of more obscure more
recent characters from the comics so you
can probably expect that certain
characters will show up in the
appropriate movies so Green Lantern
characters in the Green Lantern Corps
movie which is still sort of the tail
end of the DC movies that's not going to
be coming till around 2020 everybody's
been asking about Martian Manhunter I
think that's him under Hawkgirl here and
you see Green Arrow I know everybody's
been like what about Charlie Hunnam
Green Arrow Stephen Amell a long time
ago is like yeah they told me they're
not planning on putting green arrow in
the movies any time soon so we'll see if
that changes in the next couple of years
but all things in good time so it's not
like they're going to rush all of these
characters out in the first Justice
League movie they'll just tease some of
the broader concepts of the universe
then you'll start seeing them pop up
like you'll see more
command characters in the Aquaman movie
they'll probably save a bunch of them
for the second Justice League movie in a
lot of the magic based super weird
characters for Justice League dark these
are kind of low red so let me know which
other characters you spot in the
background here but I think I see
Supergirl here so pretty much any
character that's ever gotten a solo
comic on their own or been a big
character in someone else's comic in the
DC Comics universe so this is just so
cool what'll probably happen is is
they'll release a really high res
version of this when we get closer to
comic-con before the Justice League
movie but this just gets me so excited
for the future of DC movies leads to say
that Wonder Woman was amazing and
crushed it it almost made about two
hundred and fifty million dollars
worldwide as I'm posting this video
opening weekend international box office
just for example it crushed the first
Iron Man's opening box office like
that's how good it's doing right now so
be sure go see Wonder Woman check out
like a really nice huge version of this
in the movie theater because it looks
great on the big screen in Wonder Woman
is fantastic so leave all your requests
for Justice League bonus videos and I'll
be posting Wonder Woman Easter eggs in
the next couple of days while you wait
for that you can click here for my
Wonder Woman video for like the really
big concepts and some of the big twists
and you can click here for like a really
big Spider Man homecoming special with a
whole bunch of new footage thank you so
much for watching us I thought I'll see
you guys tonight
you